and more covid19 vaccines are making
their way through our local hospitals
saint rose dominican hospitals umc and
the va hospital in north las vegas
all receiving coveted doses and began
administering them
earlier today to front line health care
workers
staff at southern hills hospital called
this really a historic day after
receiving their first doses
sunrise hospital also received vaccines
and front line workers were given shots
earlier on this morning the hospital's
chief medical officer
said hope arrived at 6 05 a.m
you can feel the enthusiasm
administering the vaccine
together we can ultimately put a stop to
this
virus as i said before i'm just so
excited and the feeling is just palpable
sunrise hospital says it's ordered
roughly 2 000 doses of the vaccine and
it hopes that it will vaccinate
all of their health care workers if they
want to be vaccinated
now the covid19 vaccine distribution
continued
in southern nevada the va in north las
vegas also got their share
of the covid vaccine yesterday started
vaccinations today
they received 975 doses eight news now
reporter sally jaramillo on this story
and she was there when the first
employees rolled up their sleeves
brian it's important to note that the va
of southern nevada was the first
hospital to receive the first patient
with coven 19.
today around 10 a.m two doctors received
the vaccine and they say they're staying
hopeful
they also feel extremely prepared now
infectious deceased physician
dr jason daisley was one of the first
doctors who received the vaccine
he wants to talk with others who may be
hesitant to take it
dr myron kong was the second doctor to
get it
his two encourages others to get it and
clear up any misconceptions
this technology is actually not new it
has been done before
we just have never needed a vaccine to
be distributed on this level
so that's one two the time
frame the elements of time that will
shorten
are the things that we had used to do
before grow a vaccine
in an egg kill the vaccine produce all
of those eggs
distribute it
this is a two dose vaccine while there's
some efficiency
after the first dose dr kung says 95
percent can be achieved after the second
the window between them 21 days for a
pfizer and 28 days for
moderna after healthcare workers and
those in nursing homes get the vaccine
those in long-term facilities are next
as well as essential workers such as
emts firefighters and police officers
after that of course those 65 and above
reporting live in north las vegas sally
caramillo 8 news now